[MUSIC]
We're here today to talk to you
all about class participation.
Class participation is one of the most
important ways that you can engage with
the GSB and enhance your own learning.
But it can be hard, but at the end of
this talk, you're going to have several
effective tips to learn to
participate in an effective manner.
But first, let's take a dive
into a typical GSB classroom.
>> Shimano,
I hope you guys are on the case.
>> [LAUGH]
>> In the 1980s,
Shimano introduced a phenomenal drivetrain
that revolutionized the biking industry.
Who can tell me what was the competitive
advantage that Shimano pursued back then?
Don't make me cold call.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Cathleen?
>> I think, I'm not 100% sure, but
I think it might've been going for
perceived quality.
>> I disagree.
I'm not an expert,
by all means in the drive train,
but I really think its Wilcox.
>> Neil.
>> Shimano pursues a perceived
quality competitive advantage.
They do this in several ways.
First, integrated drive train will provide
superior riding experience for end users.
They also do marketing and
sponsorships to reinforce
the perception of quality to end users.
In terms of costs, they use for
the skills that allow for
increasing witness to pay without
the equivalent increase in price.
>> And cost.
>> How many of you have been in
classes where comments like the ones
made by Stephanie and Kathleen added
zero value to the conversation?
>> [LAUGH]
>> I know, I've been there.
And you just want to choke those people.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But, it's comments like the one
made by Lou that actually add value to
the conversation and move it forward.
So we're here today to talk to
you about class participation,
why it's important, why it's hard,
and how to do it effectively.
So why it's important?
Well, for one, it enhances learning.
Each one of you has a unique experience
and we're here to learn from each other.
The case method, which a lot of
the classes at the GSP depend on,
depend on collaboration between
the professor and the students.
We want to hear what you have to say.
So by sharing your experience, you're not
only enhancing your learning experience,
you're enhancing the learning
experience of everyone in the class.
Two, grades.
I know you all want to get good grades.
If you don't know already,
participation will account for
a large portion of your grade at the GSB.
And if you're one of those
people that are going for
the RJ Miller status, trust me,
you're going to need those points.
And if you're like me and you're going for
the friends of RJ Miller status,
then you'll also need those points.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And lastly, build reputation.
Class participation will be,
for many of you,
the first time your classmates
will hear your voice.
So try to build a reputation for
yourself from the start
through class participation.
So we know class participation is
important, but it's also really hard.
Participating in class can cause a lot of
anxiety for a host of different reasons.
There's cultural elements at play,
diverse backgrounds or limited experience.
And the social factor of
talking in a large group.
Cultural differences can be
really challenging at the GSB.
If you're coming into a new country,
you're maybe speaking a language
that isn't your first language.
In some cultures, you should really differ
to the position, the person of authority,
or it's really not common place
to descent publicly and openly.
But we want to remind
you that the majority
of the GSB students come
from all over the world.
40% of the students are international and
we have representation from
53 different countries.
So you're not alone.
How you feel, there's somebody else
in the room who feels the same way.
Another concern often comes
with your background.
I'm just an undergrad.
I'm only worked a year or two.
I don't really know anything or
I never worked in finance.
How can I participate in a Finance class?
Well, actually, asking questions is
one of the best ways to participate.
And what you bring, your background and
your experiences is really
valuable in the classroom.
And, just as a reminder,
there's all of us at the GSB come
from lots of different industries.
And even traditional
backgrounds of consulting,
finance, investing is only
forty percent of the class.
The rest of the class has
experience in manufacturing,
clean tech, government, education.
All of these things are super valuable to
the collaborative learning environment.
Finally, the social impact.
This is tricky because it's hard
to speak in a room full of people.
I mean, we've talked about how people are
more afraid of dying or people are more
afraid of public speaking than they are
dying, but Leo is here to help you address
this kind of issue and learn to
participate effectively in the classroom.
>> You all know that class
participation really is important.
You also know that it brings a lot
of risks and exciting related to it.
What we want to share with you
today is a simple framework
that will help you
succeed in the classroom.
They're based on preparation,
presence, and power.
Let's begin the preparation.
Preparation is the best way to reduce
all the excitement you may have
before first meeting class.
The first tip is quite obvious.
Just read the case, know your facts and
positions before you come to class.
It's also great when we all have
such a diverse experience, so
it would be great if ever you can
experience great social, in fact,
experience in Africa, Commercial Banking.
Bring that to the case discussion,
bring your own experience for
the benefit of the whole class.
And finally, if you still are unsure
about sharing this in a group like this,
have a small group of classmates,
the smallest of the group and
share your ideas with them before
speaking in the whole class.
Now we are prepared, it's time to go to
the classroom which is just like this.
And it is true, you all are being
evaluated a 100% of the time not only
by the professors, but
also by all of ourselves.
The first thing that you should be
concerned with is your own presence.
How are you being perceived
by your classmates?
How is your posture?
Are you keeping eye contact
with everyone or not?
And [COUGH] sorry, lastly, it's also
important to be an active listener.
Why is this important?
You don't want to make a comment that has
nothing to do with what's been discussed
or stop in a moment like I just did and
just don't know what to say.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Finally, you have preparations.
You have a great presence in class.
Now it's your turn.
You are the one to have the power
to move the conversation forward,
to really move the needle.
Bring your ideas in a succinct way and
share your own side with the whole group.
It's okay not to agree,
it's okay to make questions.
They actually help a lot so other students
can see the same subject in a totally
different way and better understand
the [INAUDIBLE] being discussed.
>> Participation is hard.
Kathleen has shared some reasons why.
We come from different backgrounds,
we come from different work experiences,
and when we got thrown into a room like
this, the social pressure is high.
It's hard but it is not impossible.
Leo shared with us the three Ps,
preparation, presence, and power.
We're now going to pass out a handout that
shares some content delivery tips for
your class participation.
As you embark today on your GSB journey
and go to your first classes and
participate inthe case method, we want
you to keep a few more things in mind.
First, keep a broad perspective.
It's one comment, in one class,
in one class session, in one quarter.
You dont need to be perfect.
If you say something that you're
not happy with, trust me,
you'll have many more opportunities.
Also, the skill set is not just
applicable in the case method
environment here at the GSB.
Learning how to participate in large
group settings will be applicable
to you as you leave the GSB and
embark on your career.
Also, learn to laugh.
Trust me, there will be a time when you
forget the case protagonist's name.
Or, there will be a time when
the class will start laughing,
like in my experience,
when you say and open your comment for
the third time with,
when I was working at the sausage factory.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Session one knows.
[LAUGH] So keep a smile on your face and
realize it's not the end of the world.
And finally, be patient.
You don't enter the GSB and
you're not going to be perfect at
your first day in your classes
on class participation.
Don't hold yourself to that
standard because we're not
holding you to that standard.
Derek Bolton did not admit you to the GSB
because you are a perfect class
participator from day one.
He admitted you because you are unique.
Because you have a unique perspective.
Because you come from unique backgrounds
with diverse experiences and
because you have something to say.
Please bring that to the classroom.
We ask you today to bring your
whole self to the classroom.
To participate and
commit to raising your hand in class.
In fact, we're going to give you
an opportunity to start today
as we now open it up for questions.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yes?
>> I wonder in your example, are you
kind of prizing the perfect comment
in a way that, maybe sometimes, saying the
wrong thing or saying a half-formed idea
helps the class get to ultimately where
everybody needs to be as opposed to just
somebody raising their hand, perfectly
outlining what they read in the case,
how it fits into what we're learning,
and therefore what the answer is.
>> We're not saying you
have to be perfect.
That's not exactly what
we're trying to say and
hopefully it didn't come across that way.
What we are saying is we want
the alleviate the stress and
anxiety of you to
actually raise your hand.
So if you go through the preparation and
think about how youcome across in class
with presence and know that you do
have the power to move the needle,
it can help you be in a place that
you're willing to raise your hand.
We, I think, all of us would agree,
that there are comments that are sometimes
half formed that aren't, maybe, correct.
They really do help move the needle and
move the conversation forward,
and we encourage those as well.
We just want to help give you tips
to help alleviate any stress or
anxiety to encourage you to raise
your hand and participate in class.
[MUSIC]